MALE SPEAKER: I'm delighted
to welcome Professor Richard
Shell from the Wharton
School of Business
at the University of
Pennsylvania, which
is where I graduated from.
And I had the pleasure,
privilege, and honor
of having professor Shell
as my negotiations professor
many years back.
And back then, at
the end of the class,
he gave us a little wallet
size card for a negotiations
framework, and for
all these years
I've carried the card with me
in my wallet every single day
and pulled it out
multiple times.
And I've told them that that
framework alone on that card
has repaid more than the
cost of my MBA education.
Now Professor Shell
has been teaching
at Wharton for 28
years, and he's
Professor of Legal Studies,
Ethics and Management--
and negotiations is one of
the things he's famed for,
both as a lecturer,
author and teacher.
But along these 28 years,
he's met many, many students
like me-- and there's many
of you in the audience--
and he would have
career discussions,
life discussions with them.
And the thing that
intrigued him-- especially
in the last few years-- is
how do each of these people
define success?
What exactly is success?
How do we pursue it?
What price are we
willing to pay?
How do we know when
we've attained it,
and how will we get there?
What is the journey that
takes you to success?
And that's what led him
to research and write
this book called "Springboard:
Launching Your Personal Search
for Success."
And the word "your"
is key to it,
because when you
read the book you'll
realize ultimately
what success is,
how you get there is each
person's individual journey.
And this is what Professor Shell
will be talking to us about.
With that, please help me
welcome Professor Shell.
[APPLAUSE]
G. RICHARD SHELL:
Thank you, [INAUDIBLE].
Thank you very much.
Thank you.
And thank you for turning out.
The subject of
success is something
that I've been
puzzled by, probably
since I was in mid-college.
And then over the years,
as my life evolves,
it became a period
of crisis to decide
what that really meant to me.
And then as I joined
the faculty of Wharton,
a period of time when I
could actually reflect on it
and do research on it and
create a course about it.
So I actually have a course
now called "The Success Course"
that's at Wharton, and
it's a semester-long trip
that every student gets to take.
And they have to write
a final paper, when
the final paper of
that course is my--
and then fill in the year--
2014, the area of success,
and how I plan to achieve it.
And my goal for that
paper is for people
to read it 10 years after
they graduate, and look back
and think to themselves
well, that's interesting.
That isn't how it worked at all.
But it gives you not
so much the destination
that you're going to
travel as the way--
the beginning of the way--
to think about how you're
going to assess that journey.
And that's what I want to
talk about for a few minutes
this afternoon.
You've got a little assessment,
the "Six Lives Exercise."
And that's something that's
in chapter one of the book,
and it's the exercise we use
in the first day of that class
to help people begin to think
about how they're implicitly
measuring success.
So I'm going to talk for
a bit, and then we're
going to get-- and see--
what kind of answers
you gave to this assessment, and
see if there's some differences
or similarities in the way
Googlers think about success
when asked to measure it across
their whole life, not just
a single domain.
So we did that.
And I think the
motivating question here
is at different stages of
your life-- it's always
the case, right after you
graduate from college,
that you have to
ask, what's next?
But it can also be the case
after your MBA program.
You have to ask, what's next?
Or after you've finished
a project at Google
and you're given the opportunity
to ask, what's next, or decide
that it's time to go from
Google to someplace else.
And then you get to
ask, what's next?
Or your spouse is relocated,
and so you have to make changes.
Or something happens in your
life that reframes who you are
and what you're trying
to do, and then you
have to confront that question.
So it is a question that comes
up multiple times in a life.
And I think that the way I've
tried to organize this book,
and the course that I teach,
is to go to two subjects.
One is, what do you think
the meaning of success
is for yourself?
And then, second,
having had some thoughts
on that subject, what are
the individual capabilities,
talents, passions, experiences
that you can uniquely
bring to achieving that
definition for yourself?
Because a lot of how to
succeed books really say
there's one path for
everybody-- set goals, network.
There's a book for every tool.
But I think it's the
case that each of you
has vastly different
aptitudes and capabilities,
and the journey
inside to discover
how best to achieve your
goals using your own abilities
is every bit as interesting
as defining the goal itself.
So one motivating
question to think
about that gives you a sense of
when you're missing something--
have you ever tried really
hard to achieve something,
achieved it, and then
fell oddly empty,
almost a sense of
who was doing that?
Why did I do that?
I think when you get
that sort of sense,
you're basically-- it's
a message that you've
been achieving
someone else's goal.
It was a goal that
you thought you
were trying to achieve
for your parents.
It was a goal you
thought you were trying
to achieve to show your brother
or your sister who is the best.
It was a goal that
you wanted to achieve
to be someone in your
high school class
or be someone in
your neighborhood.
And so it's very important to
realize, a lot of the goals
that we implicitly are motivated
by come from outside ourselves.
They are culturally induced,
media induced, family induced.
And one chance to check
on how you're doing,
whether you're moving more
from the outside in or more
from the inside out, is how
much genuine satisfaction
are you getting when you
actually get something, achieve
something, do something that
you've been striving to achieve
and exerting some
effort on, to the extent
that the satisfaction is there?
And it's not just
the satisfaction
that someone said oh, good job,
but the inner satisfaction.
That's a sign that
you're on a path
that you've defined
for yourself.
So in a sense you're
looking for other people
to congratulate you on it.
And when you just are home
at night after achieving it,
you're lying in bed and
you don't really feel it,
then you're-- got a little
work to do would be my advice
at that point.
So this subject came to
be very important to me
personally early on.
As I mentioned, my
early 20s was a kind
of period of crisis for
me, and that gave me
a sense of how
important this can
be for someone in their 20s.
I was raised in a
military family.
My dad was a general
in the Marines.
His father was a career
military officer.
My mother's father was a
career military officer.
My sister married a
And so there was
almost no doubt when
I went to college what
I was going to do.
And I was going to be a
career military officer.
And I never even
gave it much thought.
It was just the path.
So I went to college on a
full military scholarship.
I was all set to go.
Six years after graduation
I'd be either a Marine
or a naval officer.
That was my only real choice.
And everything
was going on great
until the sophomore
year in college
when, without asking
for it, I suddenly
had to confront
that wake-up call.
And for me, it was an
escalation of the Vietnam War.
My college years were right in
the middle of the Vietnam War.
The Tet Offensive had occurred
during my sophomore year.
Campuses all over
the United States
exploded-- tremendous rethinking
of what that war was about,
what our role in the world was.
And for me, really for
the first time in my life,
I was called to
answer the question
what would I be doing
as a military officer
after graduation?
And that answer came
back pretty quickly
that I would be going to
kill Vietnamese people,
with whom I had no quarrel.
And that set me on a different
path to thinking who I was
and what I ought to be doing.
It took a couple of years
to get on the journey
that I ended up on.
It was difficult, because
I had to make a phone
call to my father and tell
him that I was dropping
the military
scholarship and I was
going to become a war
resistor and a pacifist.
That was a night
that I remember.
I had written a little speech to
tell him what I planned to do,
and his response was
very interesting.
After I had read
my little speech,
there was a bit of a silence,
and then he said, are you sure?
Which was not what I
expected him to say.
And I was of course
completely unsure.
I had no idea that I was
doing the right thing.
You can't walk away
from everything
your family has
stood for generations
in a couple of
months and be sure
that you're doing
the right thing.
But I had to be sure
with him that night,
and so I said yes, I'm sure.
So that moment, basically,
was the wake-up call for me,
because up to that point
I'd been on a journey
that other people had created
for me, and after that point
I had to create my own.
And I had to create
it from scratch.
I don't recommend that,
because when you go that far
away from your family values,
your culture, what you've
been raised in, making
it all up from scratch
is a very difficult thing.
And in my case, it took
probably about 12 years
of time between that
moment and then the final
coming home again and
reuniting with my family
and embracing them.
We reconciled.
But there were periods when
I wasn't speaking with them.
The introduction of the
book tells a longer story
about a journey I
took around the world
to try to sort things out.
And suffice it to say that
when you give yourself
a one-way ticket to
someplace far away,
and you make a pledge to
yourself that you're not
going to come back
until you figure it out,
it's a different
kind of trip than one
that you're taking to go see
if you can find the Taj Majal.
For me it was an inward journey.
I spent a lot of time in
monasteries in Sri Lanka
and in South Korea.
I was even invited to
become a monk in South Korea
at a Zen monastery, which caused
me to divide the decision.
It was either
meditation hall or home.
And by that time I'd actually
come together with myself
enough to realize that
I was ready to go home.
And so then I did go
home, and ended up
living in my parents'
basement for a while
at ages older than many of you.
So if you're still not
completely sure what
you want to do, hang in there.
There's hope.
And if you end up living
in your parents' basement,
that's OK, too.
So I sorted it out.
I went to law school--
started at Wharton in 1986,
and I've been there ever since.
And I think the reason
that this subject gives me
such passion is because I
realize that a lot of people
are unsure about
what they want to do.
But the culture that we're
in, especially the confidence
culture-- whether it's at
school or at an organization--
everybody seems to think
they've got it figured out.
And they look at
other people and they
go, well, they've all
got it figured out.
So my doubts must
be sort of abnormal,
and so I'll just sort
of keep them a secret.
And I wrote the book to help
people break the secret.
It's OK not to know.
It's OK to be uncertain.
In fact, that
uncertainty is probably
the source and the
seed of the best things
that you will ever do.
And so each chapter has got
assessments in it like the one
we just did, and
gives you a chance
to think deeply about your
family, your culture, the place
you want to go, the places
that you have gone and maybe
didn't quite understand
why you went there.
So that's why the book.
I think it's fair to say that
elite education does very
little to help people
with this question.
A lot of academic work
is basically analytical.
Even if it's about the
humanities, it's analytical.
And I like to quote
Ralph Waldo Emerson.
He had a conversation with his
friend Henry David Thoreau.
Emerson said,
Harvard teaches most
of the branches of learning.
And his friend Thoreau
said yes, indeed--
all the branches and
none of the roots.
And I think my work
has been to try
to-- let's get back
to some of the roots.
Let's get back to some
of the primary ideas,
and let's get back to help
students find their own voice.
A lot of writing in college
is designed to basically teach
you write in the third
person-- some objective reality
out there.
But I think it's very
important for people
to learn to write
in the first person
and find their voice,
speak from the heart,
In The Iliad, the two teams--
the Trojans and the Greeks--
have leaders, and
every now and then
there's a great moment
where one of the leaders
gives a speech to their
troops to rally them
to the next battle.
And there's a trope in the
way that Homer wrote it.
And every time one
of the speakers
begins a speech
to his own people
he says, hear me, Achaeans.
Hear what my heart has to say.
And I think that
notion that when
you speak you should speak
what your heart has to say,
is something that
isn't that easy.
And it's something that
is well worth working on.
So the book is really
designed to help people.
And the programs we've been
working on at Wharton--
we have about half
the MBA students now
are engaged in a voluntary,
eight-week program where they
learn to talk about
their own goals,
they use the book
and other readings
to motivate themselves,
to think about the future
and themselves in a
more open-minded way.
And we've found that it's
been very, very helpful
and very powerful for them.
One quick matrix, if you
think about your career--
just narrowly, not all of
life, but just your career--
this is an interesting
diagnostic test
you can take periodically.
If you had achievement on
one side and satisfaction
on the other, and you had to
put a dot in one of these nine
cells, where would you put it?
Now I've done this
exercise with people
who are senior executives in our
five-week advanced management
program who are in
their 40s and 50s,
and you'd be amazed at
people-- even the most
accomplished people, apparently,
in business life-- how often,
when you get them to be
honest, the dots end up
pretty high on the
achievement side-- not too
many people picking low
achievement at the Advanced
Management program at Wharton--
but medium to low sometimes
on the satisfaction side.
And we create a good
enough learning community
so that people can
be honest about that.
I'll just share two
quick stories with you.
There was one fellow
who was in a program
that we were teaching a couple--
about two years ago now,
and he put his little
dot up there where
low satisfaction and
high achievement.
He said he was the head
of the North American
division of a major
Fortune 500 company,
and had achieved, as he saw it,
far beyond any level of status
that he ever could have
dreamed of for himself.
So he put himself in the
high achievement cell.
And I said why low satisfaction?
And he said well, for the last
three promotions that I've
gotten, each one has taken
me further and further away
from what I love to do the most.
And that's a trap
in corporate life.
You get promoted
and then you stop
doing the thing
that you really love
to do, and get to do the
things that they'll pay more
to do and give you a
better title to do,
but isn't anything
that's feeds your soul.
So his particular
passion was logistics,
which I thought was interesting.
He loved to get
factories to run on time.
He loved to get efficiency done.
And so as he got promoted,
he was more and more
engaged with corporate
politics and the kind of issues
that attack you when
you're at the top
of some large bureaucracy.
So he had a couple
of weeks to think
about how he could
re-craft his job
and get himself back closer
to what he really loved to do.
The other person-- there
was two of them-- who
put his dot in that
cell was 35 years old.
He just won an award for
best lawyer in Argentina.
He was a top lawyer in Argentina
for his group of lawyers.
And I said, well, that's
great-- that was obviously
high achievement.
Why low satisfaction?
He said, well, I hate law.
And so, good to
realize that at 35.
I think his future is bright.
Once you recognize
that you're basically
been getting paid
to do something
you do well but have
no excitement with.
And that's another trap.
People will pay
you a lot of money
to do something you're
good at, but that may not
be the thing that
you love to do.
And I think you have to have
those three things going
together if you want to
really begin to get down
on some real inner
satisfaction, and that
is something other people
recognize enough to pay you
for, something you're
good at, and something
that you're excited about.
So those three things
together I think
are a pretty good sweet spot.
So when you look at
success you end up
with two dimensions-- outer
dimension, achievement,
inner dimension, happiness.
If you ask most
people what success is
and they haven't
thought about it much,
they'll answer,
well, it's happiness.
I want to be happy.
That's successful.
But I want to push
that notion just a bit,
because it turns out to be
a little more complicated
than that.
Achievement-- the problem
with measuring success
and achievement is
it's always relative.
I don't care what
college you went to.
There was probably someone who
got a higher award, a better
GPA or whatever it was
that you were striving for,
and so you always
felt that sense
of pushing yourself
a little bit.
One of my favorite quotes in
the book is from H.L. Mencken:
Wealth is any
income that is more
than the income of one's
wife's sister's husband.
So if you're measuring
success in money,
pretty clearly
you're going to find
people who have more of it.
And I think that's a trap
that people get into.
Hungry ghost-- anybody
here ever studied Buddhism?
Know what a hungry ghost is?
[INAUDIBLE] of course has.
A hungry ghost is
a spiritual being
who was very greedy
and avaricious
in their regular life.
They're reborn as a being with
a body the size of an elephant
and a head the size of a pin.
And they spend the afterlife
of eternity eating, eating,
eating, eating and never
feeling the least bit
satisfied because
they can never fill
that giant body with
that tiny mouth.
Now hungry ghosts
are all around us.
There are hungry
ghosts for attention
who can never get
enough attention.
There are hungry
ghosts for status
who can never get enough power.
There are hungry
ghosts for wealth
who can never get enough money.
And every day they wake up, and
their little cup is half empty
again, and they have to spend
all day getting attention,
wealth, status, whatever it is
that they feel they're lacking.
And of course that's
sort of a trap.
If you live your life that way
it's a pretty sad circumstance,
but there are people like that.
Sometimes you need to
pick the right pond
if you're going to have a life
that you consider relatively
achieved.
If you pick only the biggest
ponds with the most competitive
environment, it's pretty easy
to find yourself discouraged
and depressed after
a little while.
We do that to our
students, of course.
Those of you who
went to Penn-- there
are a whole group up here--
you probably remember this.
When you are admitted
to a top college,
they bring you in on
the first day or two,
and they have everybody
there and they celebrate
how wonderful you are and
how much you've achieved.
But then they do
a terrible thing.
They say, OK, how many of
you were valedictorians
of your high school class?
Raise your hand.
And all these hands go up.
And how many of you
got 800 on your SATs?
Hands go up.
There's one in the
back right there.
Yeah.
And as soon as you
look around and realize
that what got you there won't
get you to the next place,
it's an upsetting thought,
because what are you
going to measure success as now?
And if you haven't done the
work from the inside out,
if you've only been measuring
it relative to everybody
around you, then you're
going to feel a little lost.
And I think it's fair to say
quite a few students check out
after that first semester.
They realize that
there's something wrong,
that they can't be the high
school student they were.
Then you find them
skating and not
really giving it
that much effort
or self-handicapping
their own performance.
So that could be a trap.
The OK plateau is
an interesting place
to be-- not my term,
another author,
but-- that's sort of a place
where everything's working OK.
The problem with
the OK plateau is
you have to take a risk
to move in any direction,
and people sometimes get
comfortable on the OK plateau
and so they stop taking risks.
And once you're
on the OK plateau
and you stop taking
risks, where do you stay?
Right there on the OK plateau.
So you need to keep that
quality of energy, excitement,
willingness to take
risks if you're
going to really let the
achievement thing work.
And then I think
there's a real trap
that I think everybody needs
to address on the achievement
side, and that is
what's your metaphor?
There's a lot of metaphors
around for success.
The most common one is
this-- success is a ladder.
And of course, the
problem with a latter
is that you get to
the top and then what?
You have to have what-- have
another letter, I guess.
But it's a pretty
limiting metaphor.
It's all about status.
It's only about career.
It doesn't really give
you much inner energy.
One that I like is this--
an image of success
might be the ripples coming
out from an impact on a pond.
And the question there is
how many people have you
influenced in a positive way?
And you measure
success that way,
rather than according
to some place
you are on a set of rungs.
But whether you like either one
of those, my challenge to you
do is if you want to understand
success for yourself,
you have to understand
your own metaphor.
And so that's a little homework.
How would you conceptualize
success for yourself?
What image would work for you?
All right-- happiness.
If you're going to say
that success is happiness,
then you'd better
define happiness.
And many people-- when you
actually scratch them on that--
don't have a whole
lot of definition.
And I think the danger is if
you just say it's happiness,
and you don't have a
definition for happiness, then
what have you done?
You just shifted an
uncertain word over
to another uncertain
word, and you really
haven't gained a
whole lot of insight.
The research on
happiness-- and Penn
is a great center for
research on happiness.
We have the Positive
Psychology Center,
and they've done a
lot of work on this.
Basically, there are three ways
that people look at happiness.
One is a lot of
positive mood states.
The problem with that
is we know from research
that most people have
a genetic set point,
and they're not
going to go too much
higher than a standard deviation
above that or below that
no matter what happens.
And it seems unfair to define
success by just whether you
got a good happiness
gene or not.
And then, of course,
there's the problem
Dan Gilbert at Harvard
discovered, which is we're
terrible predictors
of what's going
to put us in a
positive mood state.
You can say, well, I'll be
happy when I get married.
But you have the
wedding, and the wedding
doesn't make you happy.
Now what?
You could say, I'd be
miserable if I lost my job.
But then you lose your
job, and actually that's
the door that opens that gets
you to exactly the thing you
needed to do, and you're
not at all unhappy about it.
So running your life based
on predictions about what's
going to make you
happy or unhappy
turns out to be a
pretty flawed compass.
Retrospective accounts
of your life--
you're dying, you're on
your death bed, someone says
were you happy?
Is that what it's all about?
You say yes, it was
a successful life.
You say no, it was
an unsuccessful life.
So what if you get
run over by a car.
You don't have time
for anybody to ask.
Does that mean you didn't
really-- doesn't count?
The problem with
retrospective accounts
is, I could give you your
favorite flavored cookie
and you would retrospectively
say you were happier.
I can give you a bitter pill
and retrospectively you say, not
so happy.
So we can manipulate
your moods about the past
just like we can manipulate
your moods in the present.
There is a form of
happiness that I
think is really powerful,
and I would definitely
associate with the word success.
There are a lot of
different words for this.
Aristotle called it eudaimonia--
flourishing, thriving, joy.
There's a Hebrew term, simcha,
which normally means happiness,
like you're happy
with your friends.
But a rabbi that
one of my students
discovered defined it this
way-- simcha, he said,
is the feeling that
comes when you're
doing what you should be doing.
The feeling that
comes when you're
doing what you should be doing.
Now that might not
be doing something
that's just a positive
mood state thing.
That could be sitting
with someone who's ill
or visiting someone
in the hospital
or going out of your way to
perform a favor for a friend
that's actually
requires some sacrifice.
So this simcha idea--
very, very powerful,
but hard to predict
when you're going
to get it-- could come as you're
walking across the Googleplex
just at sunset and something
strikes you about nature;
could come when you're just
about to drift off to sleep
and you have a
memory of your mother
or your father that
was a wonderful time.
It's a gift.
Hawthorne once said that
happiness of this kind
is like a butterfly.
If you try to catch
it, it's hard.
But if you sit still,
sometimes they'll
come and rest on your shoulder.
So this kind of
happiness is worthy,
but it may not be
the kind of thing
you can pursue the way Jefferson
said we should pursue it.
So it's not so simple,
this happiness thing.
I'll give you one
definition and then
we'll look at your
Six Lives Exercise.
I was at a Wharton seminar on
happiness, as it turns out.
And it was a global study
of economic incomes and well
being.
And there were about
12 of us there,
and they were doing
a regression analysis
across all these different
countries and all
these surveys.
And as the seminar
began, this guy
walked into the classroom
who was obviously
a member of the public.
He was dressed in a flannel
shirt and a very working man
looking guy, probably
working on a crew outside.
And we welcome the
public to our seminars,
but we always wonder
what they'll say.
So we sort of hold our
breath sometimes when
someone comes in from the
outside to an academic setting.
So he came down and sat next
to me at the end of the table,
and I noticed his hands were
working man's hands-- very
interesting looking guy.
And he listened very politely
to the whole presentation,
and then there was a
call for questions.
And somebody asked about
the butane dataset,
and then he raised his hand.
He said, excuse me, and the
presenter said, well, yes sir.
He said, I'm just a
member of the public
and I'm not really an
expert like you are,
but you're talking
about happiness
and you're talking about money.
He said, I don't see
really what those two
things have to do
with each other.
He said, as far as I
can tell, happiness
is just three things-- good
health, meaningful work,
and love.
You have that, you're happy.
And there was this dead silence.
And the presenter
said thank you.
And then someone else
asked another question
about another dataset, and
the conversation went along,
and he shifted out the back.
So I was sitting there and
I was thinking, my gosh.
Wharton has just been visited
by a wise angel who told us
the meaning of life
and nobody listened.
Very interesting.
But the challenge I
would have for you
is this: the wise
angel-- I ended up
calling him the wise angel.
I talk about him in the book.
But the wise angel had to
find happiness for himself.
I don't know that that's the
right definition of happiness.
I think you can still
be happy and your health
couldn't may be not the best.
You can be happy and have
work that you get a paycheck,
and you're living
your meaningful life
outside of work.
You can have-- love
can come and go,
and I think there are
moments when you can be happy
as you're searching for love,
even if you haven't found it.
But he had an idea for his own
life of what that word meant,
and my challenge to
you is while you're
looking for the metaphor
for achievement,
find a definition of happiness
that really sums it up for you.
And don't just
imagine that there's
some intuitive thing out there.
There's some
concrete things that
bring you happiness,
whatever you mean by it,
and I think it's important
to think about those as you
think about success.
All right.
So now I just want
to quickly give you
a chance to reveal your
own concepts of success.
We did this little
Six Lives Exercise.
There are six
different people that
were profiled very
briefly in the story.
I know that we've got
a remote audience.
I hope they got a chance
to do this on the website.
But I just want to survey
the number one and number six
choices for each of these.
And let's just see what
came up for people.
And do we have-- is
someone, you've got a mic?
Excellent.
So you might have a
chance to comment.
So how many people ranked
the wealthy investor
as number one, the
number one life?
One, two, three, four.
OK.
How many people number six
for the wealthy investor?
All right, another four.
So maybe you could give
this gentleman the mic here.
You picked the wealthy
investor number one.
What was your thought as
you ranked him number one?
AUDIENCE: I think the idea that
he's taking bets that are big
and going after
them, and he's having
an impact on the
world that he defines
in a way that's positive.
He's got a lot of people
he's interacting with,
and he's-- seems like he has the
chance to get his opinion out
there and make an impact
that others respect and are
listening to.
G. RICHARD SHELL:
[INAUDIBLE] appealing.
So he seems to be
having a lot of impact
and he seems to have a lot
of options, a lot of variety
in that life, and be
very appealing for that.
Who ranked that number six?
This gentleman here.
You could pass the
mic over to him.
Why last?
AUDIENCE: He sold his business
and became a libertarian.
He's given everything away.
He doesn't empathize
with people.
He doesn't-- there's
no one there anymore.
He's just got money.
G. RICHARD SHELL: So there is
a sense of everything's alone.
There's no marriage partner.
There's no significant other.
He's hang gliding, he's doing
all these individual things,
but not-- and impacting the
world in a political way,
but in a political way that's
consistent with 100% autonomy.
So that doesn't appeal to you.
A lot of people don't pick
that one because there's really
no family story behind
that one, and there
is for most of the others.
OK-- banker.
Who ranked the
banker number one?
Banker for number one.
Anybody?
OK.
I Hold your thought
for just a second.
Banker for number six.
OK.
What appealed to you
about the banker?
AUDIENCE: I think
it seemed like she
has a nice work-life
balance, so she's
pretty successful
in her work life,
but she also has a
family-- or a daughter
that she can
dedicate herself to.
And she's not married, but
she seems pretty OK with that,
because she puts her
energy into her daughter.
G. RICHARD SHELL: OK.
So it's a lot of loyalty,
a lot of commitment,
and definitely another
person in her life
that's very, very important.
One of the things
that people often
find appealing
about that life is
that she's defending
her value of success,
and her friends are saying
you should abandon it.
We don't think your
life is meaningful.
But her point of
view is, yes it is.
It's the life I've chosen.
AUDIENCE: Decision.
G. RICHARD SHELL: Yeah.
And there's a lot of
courage behind that.
OK.
Number six?
AUDIENCE: I think for me
family is extremely important--
or, sorry, banker.
The idea of just having love
in your life is important,
and having a
daughter is awesome.
But I think dating other
people or finding love,
and having someone
else define love
for you is something that
really tears me apart,
and that really is something
that's terrorizing Jane.
She doesn't date a lot
of different people.
And I think the
other part of it is
that she has a
daughter who she's
devoted her entire life to.
But I'm basically assuming that
this daughter may or may not
appreciate everything
that she does,
and appreciation is
also huge for me.
And so I feel like when
you devote yourself
to someone else,
there's never this--
G. RICHARD SHELL: An echo.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
An echo, essentially.
G. RICHARD SHELL: OK.
AUDIENCE: So those
are my two points.
G. RICHARD SHELL: Yeah, yeah.
So the fact that there's no
intimate partner in that life
can very definitely affect
people's sense of happiness
for that one.
And then-- it's a child
with a severe disability.
If you don't happen
to have experience
of such a child
in your own world,
that feels very
one-sided, and it
could feel like you're
sort of give, give, give,
but not a lot of get.
People who know families with
children of that type, who
have had that kind
of challenges,
often report to me that
that's actually incorrect,
and it's not something
that you miss at all.
It's actually a tremendously
warm sense of reciprocity.
So a lot of what we do
when we pick these lives
is interpolate
from our experience
into something that's
filling in the blanks.
And so it's incomplete.
But I would point
this out to you--
your choices are going to
be informed by nothing more
profound than those implicit
assumptions about what
will make you happy
or not, and so they're
worth questioning and
looking at carefully.
OK.
Teacher.
Who voted for the
teacher number one?
Anybody?
We got one-- one, one, two.
OK.
Teacher number six?
AUDIENCE: So the teacher
to me was the one
who seemed like she was creating
the most personal human value
for other people.
She was really helping others
grow in a way that would really
affect their lives more so
than any of the others to me.
G. RICHARD SHELL: OK.
So that life
definitely has a sense
of that ripple effect,
impacting other people--
and to excellence, to helping
them become fulfilled.
And that none of the other
lives had quite the same degree
of intimate
connection like that.
Why number six?
Who had six over here?
AUDIENCE: I put
her as number six
mostly because I
think it's great
if she can impact all
these other lives,
but if you can't keep
your family together,
then-- I feel like
the last line there
is just indicative of
much greater problems
happening at home.
And so--
G. RICHARD SHELL: The fact
that she's lost connection
with one of her
children, it does
affect a lot of
people, who see that
as a huge black hole in
their happiness side,
and interpret, maybe,
a kind of preoccupation
with helping others succeed, but
not paying the same attention
to her own kids, and there's
a price being paid there.
I will say this.
Again, we interpret these
stories within our own life
story, and when I ranked the
teacher number one-- of course,
I am a teacher, but I guess
that's-- but I am the child who
was alienated, but I came home.
And so I know that
story ends well,
so I don't have as
much fear of it.
OK, interesting-- both
valid points of view.
The nonprofit leader-- number
one for nonprofit leader?
Got one here.
OK.
Number six for nonprofit leader?
AUDIENCE: I like that he's
had multiple experiences
and has found his
way to happiness.
So he started off as an
investment banker or something
and figured out what that
lifestyle was and determined
for himself that that's
not what he meant.
I also think there's a
financial aspect of that,
that means he's financially
secure enough to not do that
anymore.
And third, I guess
he has a strong core
family, a strong
commitment to his family,
and is finally getting to
something that he's really
passionate about.
So I feel like he's
just taken this path
to figure out what he wants
to do, is in, I assume,
a comfortable enough
financial situation to do it,
and is teaching his family
the same kind of values
that he believes in.
G. RICHARD SHELL: Interesting.
So there's a-- you can just
hold that for a second--
so there's a life
where, essentially,
the person's already
in the next chapter.
They're taking the skills that
they learned in chapter one.
They're applying them
differently in chapter two.
The second chapter has
got a little more purpose,
at a spiritual dimension
or social purpose,
than the first
chapter does, and that
seems to be working for them.
Why number six?
AUDIENCE: I feel that he
was a nonprofit executive,
but before that he
was an executive,
had great success from the
outside and realized that.
So for me that was a
failure for him initially.
He realized that that
was a good thing,
then he came down to doing
what he thought he liked.
But I think that by forcing
his children to go over there,
he is again making the
same mistake-- that he
did the same mistake in
his own life of choosing
the wrong part, probably
because of outside influence,
and he is making that
influence happen to his kids.
G. RICHARD SHELL: Interesting.
So it is often the
case that people
have this feeling that
he's dragging these five
children to what will be a
family disaster in Africa.
I mean, the movie
begins when they
get there and doesn't
work out so well.
I think-- I had a very
interesting experience
with someone who voted number
six for this life in Boston.
I was doing a Boston Club
talk for the Wharton School,
and a woman ranked this life
number six, and I said why,
and she said, my parents were
evangelical missionaries,
and they dragged us
everywhere, and they never
paid attention to us.
And so, for her,
that fantasy was
realized in not working out.
So for me, I'd moved every
year when I was a kid.
My dad was in the
military, and moving around
was just sort of normal to me.
So I think kids
sometimes do adjust.
It just depends
on how you see it.
But I think that
inside-outside thing
was an interesting
comment on that one.
So did we get to them all?
I guess we have the stone mason.
And the what?
AUDIENCE: Tennis player?
G. RICHARD SHELL:
The tennis player.
Let's do the tennis
player first.
Quick-- tennis
player number one?
OK.
If we can get the mic back
here to this young lady
in the second from the back row?
Pass that on back.
And tennis player number six?
Anybody?
Tennis player number six?
OK.
AUDIENCE: I think
tennis player number one
because she had seemed
to achieve success
in the three main areas.
She had excelled in an art
or sport-- something where
she became the top
of her field and had,
along with that work,
professional success.
She had given back to the
community by doing a non-profit
and she also had succeeded
in having a family.
And I feel like the negative
thing that was mentioned there
in terms of her family
and work balance
is something that is constantly
a struggle for almost everyone.
I don't know when you
would not have that.
So yeah, that's
why I ranked her.
G. RICHARD SHELL: Great.
OK.
So a trifecta for
the tennis pro.
Number six?
AUDIENCE: She describes
her life as a tough life,
and that just
sounds so sad to me.
For someone to have all of
this and then to describe
their life as tough
is like, wow, you're
not doing the thing
that you want to do.
And then she goes on
to say that she doesn't
get to spend as much
time with her children,
and children is
incredibly important.
The fact that she's adopted
and all those kind of things,
I feel like she's
doing something
different than what she
actually wants to do.
G. RICHARD SHELL: Interesting.
So it doesn't sound to you as
much like a life she's chosen.
A lot of people see
that life and they
see the father teaching the
child tennis at the age of five
without a whole lot of
options on the child's side.
And that she's still
executing on the talent
that she was taught,
but maybe not the talent
that she would feel
the most agency with.
So that's another
point of view on it.
Now, finally, stone mason.
Number one for the stone mason?
OK.
All right.
So hand the mic back to
this young lady back here.
And number six for
the stone mason?
OK.
We've got one in the front.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I thought the stone mason
sounded like he had just
found a lot of meaning
through what he was pursuing,
both from his family and having
this hands-on profession.
And I think-- at
least for me, who
works in a very
data-driven, totally
not hands-on profession--
that is a very romantic idea,
to create things
with their hands.
G. RICHARD SHELL:
Very appealing.
A lot-- see, the
stone mason actually
gets to touch
everything that he makes
and see the result of everything
he makes, not part of a machine
making a big thing-- someone
making the whole thing.
So the crafts person--
very, very appealing.
And of course the family
side of the stone mason story
is totally integrated, right?
I mean, you've got children.
He's building homes
for the children,
and that feels [INAUDIBLE].
Well, let me give--
number six is
going to get a chance
here in the front.
So that's an appealing
life for that reason.
Why number six?
AUDIENCE: I think
it was because he
doesn't have a lot
of broad impact.
So I think he's done stuff for
his family, which is awesome,
but didn't seem
like he had impact
in his community or
the world at large.
G. RICHARD SHELL: He's
not even on "Stone Mason
Weekly" as a cover
story, you know?
AUDIENCE: Exactly.
Exactly.
And that he had trouble
with money as well.
I think when you
have a larger family
and having trouble
with money, there
could be other problems
there that maybe just
haven't come out yet.
G. RICHARD SHELL: Yeah.
So financial
security is certainly
a value, and something
that most people think
about when they think
about happiness together.
You had a comment?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I think, even though he didn't
make the most amount of money
out of everyone on this list,
he had the most amount of pride.
And I thought that that was the
immediate word that jumped up
to me after reading this is
it's the most authentic story.
It reminded me of the wise
angel who crashed your meeting.
And so that life's about
good health, meaningful work,
and that's exactly what
this guy's legacy was about.
G. RICHARD SHELL: Yeah.
So meaningful work is
an interesting concept.
My time is up, so I'm
going to wrap it up.
But I think it's
something-- I have
a chapter on meaningful work--
and I think you guys at Google
seem to have an elevated
value on the notion
of meaningful work,
and integration
between work and life.
Looking just-- I've
never been here before,
but looking around your campus,
sensing the different things
that people are valuing it's
just everywhere in evidence--
but I think it's important to
realize that meaningful work is
not about the work.
Meaningful work is about the
meaning you bring to the work.
And there are people
here, I'm sure,
who are not enjoying
meaningful work,
but who look like they are.
And the opposite is also true.
There may be people who
are on the security force
or helping with valet
parking or doing things
that you think aren't
all that meaningful.
But they may bring
meaning to those jobs
in a way that is
very, very authentic.
I like to say that the people
who find meaningful work
are a legion of the
secretly successful.
They are not people
that you read about.
They're not people that
you get stories about.
They're people who've found
success for themselves
in the meaning of what they do,
in the relationships they have,
in their ability to
love and be loved.
And it's not so clear that the
obvious things that we value
bring those.
I think it's something
that everybody
brings to the work they do.
So I'll leave you with
that happy thought
that you are in control of the
meaning in your work, which
means you can make
it more meaningful.
But you can also recognize that
what you thought was meaningful
isn't and make a change.
Thanks very much
for your attention.
[APPLAUSE]